we're told you have a solid that you
know is mostly sodium chloride you
suspect that it might have or it may
have some sodium iodide potassium
chloride or lithium chloride as well
when you analyze a sample you see that
it contains 73 percent chlorine by mass
is the sample pure sodium chloride if
not what else does it likely have in it
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out and it will likely be
useful to have a periodic table handy to
do it alright so the way we're going to
approach it is we're going to think
about each of these compounds and try to
figure out the percent chlorine by mass
and to do that we have to think about
the molar masses of the various
constituent atoms or the various
constituent elements that make up those
compounds and to figure out the molar
mass for each element I just have to
look at its average atomic mass and say
okay I'm gonna have that many grams per
mole if I have a mole of that atom
sodium chlorine iodine potassium and
lithium and the sodium's average atomic
mass is twenty-two point nine nine
chlorine is thirty five point four five
nine is 126 point nine zero potassium is
thirty-nine point one zero and lithium
is six point nine four and so now I can
remove my periodic table of elements and
so let's first think about sodium
chloride so percent chlorine actually
let me make a little table here I think
that'll be the most useful thing to do
so here I will put the various compounds
compound and here I will put the percent
CL by mass by mass so first we can think
about sodium chloride and I'll do all of
these in a different color just to make
things interesting
so sodium chloride so chlorines molar
mass is thirty five point four five
grams per mole and then we need to
divide that by the molar mass of the
entire compound so that's going to be
the molar mass of sodium at twenty-two
point nine nine grams per mole plus the
molar mass of chlorine again at thirty
five point four five grams per mole so
we have 35 point four five divided by
open parenthesis twenty-two point nine
nine plus thirty five point four five
close the parenthesis then I get it
equal so it looks like it's a little bit
over sixty percent and that's actually
enough for us to go on because if this
is approximately sixty one percent we
see that that's very different than
seventy three percent so already it's
very clear that two the first question
is the sample pure sodium chloride no
it's not because it has a different
percentage of chlorine by mass and pure
sodium chloride would this would be what
pure sodium chloride would look like so
it must have been mixed in with
something that has a higher percentage
of chlorine by mass so let's look at the
other candidates so we can look at
sodium iodide so sodium iodide what's
its percent chlorine by mass going to be
well this has no chlorine by mass so
this is zero so if you had sodium iodide
mixed in with sodium chloride that would
reduce the average that would reduce the
percent chlorine by mass it wouldn't
increase it so we already can rule out
this character let's look at the next
candidate potassium chloride I'll write
that right over here potassium chloride
and so it's percent chlorine would be
the molar mass of chlorine 35 point four
five divided by the molar mass of the
entire compound and so that would be the
molar mass of potassium thirty-nine
point one zero plus the molar mass of
chlorine 35 point four five
and we could try to calculate this but
even when you look at the numbers you
can see that the denominator here it
this denominator right over here is
bigger than what we had for sodium
chloride so and we have the same
numerator so if the denominator is
bigger that means we're going to get a
lower value than 61% this is less than
61% and since this has a lower percent
chlorine by mass if it was mixed in it
would average down from 61% it wouldn't
go up to set 73% so we can rule that one
out as well and now let's look at this
last candidate and I'm feeling good
about it because something got mixed in
so let's look at lithium lithium
chloride
what is its percent chlorine by mass
well it's going to be the molar mass of
chlorine 35 point four five divided by
the molar mass of the entire compound
and I'll just write chlorines molar mass
and I'm going to add that to the molar
mass of lithium which is actually quite
low six point nine four grams per mole
so once again when we compare two sodium
chloride we have the same numerator we
have the same numerator but we clearly
have a smaller denominator this value is
smaller than this value and the other
number is the same so this has a smaller
denominator which means that the whole
value is going to be larger this is
going to be greater than sixty one
percent we take thirty five point four
five divided by open parenthesis six
point nine four plus thirty five point
four five close parenthesis is equal to
it's roughly 84% chlorine by mass so
this thing is approximately 84% chlorine
by mass so that does the trick
this if you had some lithium chloride
mixed in with your sodium chloride it
could increase or it would increase the
percent chlorine by mass above sixty one
percent and actually based on these
values based on the 61 percent the 84
percent and the 73 percent you could
actually figure out what percent is your
sample of sodium chloride and lithium
chloride if you assume those are the
only two things in it